you're the wing yeah yeah yeah well i
don't have any nicknames now i'm [ __ ]
41. what are you talking about your
nickname's the winner no i know but
people don't say actually i was at the
gas station the other day so i was like
hey the wing
bro so there you go it's catching up bro
i'm gaining popularity i was at er one
yesterday picking up food between shows
this 50-something-year-old lady comes up
to me and goes hey oops don't rip
kristen anymore right hell yeah dude she
was being made a mistake right yeah she
started laughing as hard she made a
mistake right yeah i watched the 50.
you left a little drag time just to bait
him in on that what do you mean the clip
we saw yeah you i there was like a
i don't know if i was gonna ride away i
let him in yeah you you you left a
little
and then no dude it's like it's like no
it's like hopscotch and you let you you
know no it's like doubled really and i
saw an opportunity and i was like oh
he's right you don't want dead air yeah
yeah i'm a professional i'm going to
jump in and you guys oops i'm like okay
we should talk about your youtube
comments they're critical of real weird
things
[Music]
or is it that they're not looking at it
right because you're growing and your
penis isn't so it's not necessarily
smaller
i didn't
oh i'm with jeff on the system let you
i wasn't breathing i was in the middle
of [ __ ] talking you know you know
or or or it's a relay it's a relay and
i'm like this waiting and i thought you
were done but you were gonna continue to
run on when i see you in the wing
waiting and i have more to say i have to
[ __ ] talk even faster because i'm
like here he [ __ ] comes daddy's
jumping in hannibal ready with the oops
yeah you were ready
i'm always ready with you because he's
used to the laughter
yeah used to though like a sea of light
you never you don't go oops to your
audience when they laugh over you no no
no
oops hey
it wasn't done what are you doing here
i'll wait till you're done laughing yeah
yeah i get mad at you yeah usually the
oops is towards brian cowan because
he'll do it a lot oh yeah i interrupt
all the time well
we always have [ __ ] to say you know
we're committed i get it sometimes i
can't wait but i'm getting better i used
to be way worse at it yeah i remember
rogan's like dude you gotta let people
talk oh really especially if it's
one-on-one he's like you gotta learn i
don't even try yeah i'm getting i'm
getting better at it i've only been
doing it for nine years i was only i
wasn't even good at a dinner last night
it was something if i thought of
something i was like
funny man
that's how i talk it's how people talk
yeah